i've been enjoying meditating with the
waking up app recently
it makes me think about the origins of
cognition
and consciousness so let me ask where do
thoughts come from
well that's that's a very difficult
question to answer uh
subjectively they appear to come from
nowhere
right i mean it's just they they come
out of
some kind of mystery that is at our
backs
subjectively right so which is to say
that
if you pay attention to the nature of
your
mind in this moment you realize that you
don't know what you're going to think
next right now you're expecting to think
something that
seems like you authored it right you
know you're not unless you
you're schizophrenic or you have some
kind of thought disorder where you
where your thoughts seem fundamentally
foreign to you they do have a
a kind of signature of of selfhood
associated with them
uh and people readily identify with them
they feel like
what you are i mean this is the thing
this is the spell that gets broken
with meditation our default state is to
feel
identical to the stream of thought
right which is fairly paradoxical
because how could you
as a mind as a self you know if there if
there were such a thing as a self
how could you be identical to the next
piece of language
or the next image that just
springs into into conscious view
but and you know meditation
is ultimately about examining that that
point of view closely enough so as to
unravel it and
feel the the freedom that's on the other
side of that identification
but the um subjectively
thoughts simply emerge right and you
don't think them before you think them
right there's this
first moment where you know just anyone
listening to us or watching us now
could perform this experiment for
themselves and just imagine
something or remember something you know
just just pick a memory any memory
right you've got a storehouse of memory
just promote one
to consciousness did you pick that
memory i mean let's say you remembered
breakfast yesterday or you remembered
what you said to your
spouse before leaving the house or you
remembered
what you watched on netflix last night
or you remembered
something that happened to you when
you're four years old whatever it is
right it first it wasn't there
and then it appeared and
that is not a i'm sure we'll get to the
topic of free will
ultimately uh that's not evidence of
free will
right why are you so sure by the way
it's very interesting
after no no free will of my own yeah um
everything just appears right but what
else could it do
and so that's that's the subjective side
of it objectively
you know we have every reason to believe
that many of our thoughts all of our
thoughts
are at bottom
what some part of our brain is doing
neurophysiologically i mean
these are the products of some kind of
neural
computation and neural um representation
when you're talking about memories is it
possible to pull the string
of thoughts to try to get to its root
to try to dig in past the the obvious
surface subjective experience of
like the thoughts pop out of nowhere is
it possible to somehow get closer to the
roots
of where they come out of from the the
firing of the cells
or is it a useless pursuit to dig that
to dig into that direction
well you can get closer to many many
subtle contents in
consciousness right so you can notice
things more and more clearly and have a
landscape of mind open up
and become more differentiated and more
interesting
and if you take psychedelics you know it
opens
up you know why depending on what you've
taken and the dose you know
it opens in directions and to an extent
that you know very few people imagine
would be possible but for having had
those experiences
but this idea of you getting closer
to something to the the datum of of your
mind or such as something of interest in
there
or something that's more real is um
is ultimately undermined because there's
no place from which you're
getting closer to it there's no your
part of that journey right like
we we tend to start out you know whether
it's
in meditation or or in any kind of
self-examination
or you know taking psychedelics we start
out
with this default point of view of uh
feeling like we're the kind of on the
the rider on the horse of consciousness
or we're the
we're the man in the boat going down the
stream of consciousness
right but we're so we're differentiated
from
what we know cognitively uh
introspectively but that feeling of
being differentiated that feeling of
being a self that can strategically pay
attention
to some contents of consciousness
is what it's like to be identified with
some
part of the stream of thought that's
going uninspected right like that
it's a false point of view and when you
see that and cut through that then this
sense of
this this notion of going deeper kind of
breaks apart because really there is no
depth ultimately everything is right on
the surface everything there's no center
to consciousness there's just
consciousness in its contents and that
those those contents can change
vastly again if you drop acid you know
the the contents change
but there's in some sense that doesn't
represent
a position of depth versus the continuum
of depth versus surface
has broken apart
you